عند مدخل مرفا ايطالي طرابلس يتجمع
العشرات من عائلات المهاجرين الذين تم
انقاذهم يحاولون العثور على احبائهم او
معرفه مصيرهم اذ يتخوفون من تسليم
السوريين الناجين الى النظام السوري
تتصدى لهم القوه البحريه وتفرق الحشد
وتبعدهم عن المكان
لقد تم للذوي تجنب ماساه باعجوبه الجيش
اللبناني اعلن عن انقاذ اكثر من 200 مهاجر
بعد ان غرق القارب الذي كان يقولهم قباله
سلعته كما اكد انتشال جثتي شخصين غرقا
اثناء عمليه الانقاذ
بس طلعوا لنا اولادنا بدنا اولادنا ما
بدنا نرجع على سوريا نحن ما بنرجع على
سوريا بنقتل حالنا بنقتل حالنا قدام باب
وريين لكن بينهم اكثر من 50 لبنانينيا
فمنذو ان غرقت البلاد في ازمه اقتصاديه
غير مسبوقه يحاول الكثيرون عبور البحر على
امل الانتقال الى البر الاوروبي رغم
التكلفه الباهضه لهذه الرحلات
[موسيقى]
انا وواحد الناس بدي ارجع وبدي اسافر انا
كنت رايح مع اخي بس انا ما اتامنت معي
المصاري لحتى اروح مع اخي لكن هذه
المحاولات تنتهي احيانا بماسا في سبتمبر
الماضي خلف غرق وقارب قباله سواحل طرطوس
100 قتيل في ذلك الحين اعتقلت اجهزه الامن
السوريه عددا كبيرا من الناجين بعد وصولهم
الى بر الامان وابلغت ذويهم بانهم لا
يزالون مفقودين